One of the issues we haven't dove into too
deeply around here is gun control.
The contentious, often venomous debate about
guns has been part of some of the conversations
we've had on The Rubin Report, especially
when talking about limited government, constitutional
authority, states rights and even freedom
of speech, but it has rarely been the focus
itself.
Interestingly, gun control is one of the issues
I get the most emails about, with people usually
asking my personal feelings about the second
amendment and whether I believe in a right
to bear arms.
You're not gonna believe this, but I think
there is a sane middle ground we can find
in the gun discussion that falls somewhere
between everyone should have a bazooka and
nobody should have a handgun.
First off, very clearly and without reservation
I am a supporter of the 2nd amendment.
The 2nd amendment specifically states, "A
well regulated Militia, being necessary to
the security of a free State, the right of
the people to keep and bear Arms, shall not
be infringed."
This is interesting wording because it guarantees
the right of a citizen to protect themselves
from both other citizens and the state itself
by having the ability to own a gun.
The guarantee to life, liberty and pursuit
of happiness which is enshrined in the Declaration
of Independence isn't only for the government
to ensure for you.
Actually, it's quite the reverse.
It is incumbent on you to protect your life,
liberty and pursuit of happiness, even from
the government if need be.
In many ways this is the essence of individualism.
While the state and the government are an
important facilitator of our rights, it ultimately
up to us, the individual to make sure we are
truly protected from people and governments
who would take those rights away.
As I often say, however, two things can be
true at once.
While having a populace that can defend itself
is important, at the same time there really
is little doubt to me that we do have a gun
problem in America.
Whether we're talking about school shootings
which happen all too often, or assassinations
of police officers as happened in Dallas last
year, there can be no doubt the gun is the
weapon of choice when someone wants to indiscriminately
kill as many people as possible.
I should pause and separate mass shootings
from terrorism specifically, where terrorists
usually use some sort of explosive to kill
as many as possible, though recently we've
seen guns, knives and even cars and trucks
thrown into the mix.
And it's important to remember that the weapon
itself doesn't make the distinction between
a criminal act or terrorism, the ideology
behind the act does.
The fact that there are many ways to kill
people, does bring up an interesting idea
about guns.
If I had an assault rifle or any other gun,
I wouldn't go into a school or a church or
anywhere else and kill randomly people.
Likewise, I've got some pretty great kitchen
knives and I don't go into mosques or temples
and stab anyone.
This shows that the gun itself is just the
tool and the issue around gun control is much
deeper.
We should be having an honest conversation
about issues like mental health, the overuse
and side effects of prescription drugs, the
insidious nature of evil ideologies, the access
to guns that mentally unstable people have,
and much more.
Unfortunately, we seem to only have these
conversations at the worst possible time,
right after another shooting.
This gets the anti gun crowd in a frenzy to
take away all guns, and it gets the pro gun
crown to think the government is going to
come to their house and take their guns.
Don't believe me?
Just check out how gun sales which skyrocketed
under Obama, but now have dipped under Trump.
All of these issues are just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to guns.
I think there are good people on both sides
of the debate who just see a different solution,
partly because they are seeing a different
problem in the first place.
Some see this truly as a problem with guns
themselves while some see this as a larger
societal problem with mental health, but perhaps
there is merit to both arguments.
Joining me today to unpack this highly charged
discussion is Antonia Okafor.
Antonia is a second amendment advocate, who
spends most of her energy pushing for legislation
to allow woman to carry guns on college campuses.
As a young, black conservative, she's found
herself on the outside of what the mainstream
says someone who like her should believe.
We'll talk about her political evolution from
a Obama voter to a Trump supporter and why
she thinks that a woman's right to defend
herself by herself is so important.
Without the reactionary hysteria we are usually
caught in when discussing guns, can the two
of us find some common ground?
Only one way to find out...